[موسيقى
] عادةً ما أبدأ بورقة
بيضاء وهذه مهمة شاقة
أرسمها طوال الوقت ، فأنا أرسم
دائمًا
متى أعتقد أنني كنت أرغب في أن أصبح
مهندسًا معماريًا أعتقد إلى الأبد
كمصمم
متخصص
في المباني التي تكون إما طويلة أو
عالية جدًا ،
لذا من المحتمل أن يكون برج cl هو الأحدث
حيث
سيكون أطول فندق في
العالم.
عامًا ، العقار نفسه غير معتاد
حقًا ، إنه ليس مربعًا أو مستطيلًا ،
إنه مثلث وليس كبيرًا جدًا ،
فقد تعتقد أنه مقيد
جدًا لمشروع من هذا النوع ، ومع ذلك
كان علينا أن نجعله يعمل ،
لقد أنشأنا هذه المساحة  من خلال
رفع مبنى انتظار السيارات
بحوالي تسعة أمتار ، وأعتقد حقًا
أن أعظم الابتكارات
تأتي وتكشف عن نفسها بسبب
ندرة
أنها لم تبدأ كأطول فندق
في العالم
ولكن مع تطورنا  تصميمه تطور
ليصبح أطول فندق في
العالم ،
وجدنا حلولًا
مثيرة حقًا ويمكنني أن أرى
أنه سيكون أفضل مما
اعتقدت أنه سيكون جيدًا
[موسيقى]
لك